our buddy gus ramsey uh who i have been
a
uh a friend of for quite some time who
uh
was uh one of my best producers uh back
in the day at sportscenter and is now
running
the dan patrick school of broadcasting
at full sail university
um and i want to how are you gussy how
you doing i'm good rich how are you pal
i'm good all right i'll give you the
florence ever brother go for it
yeah so the story i love to tell is it's
the summer of 87 i am
20 years old home from college and tom
seaver has retired
after uh finishing up his spear at the
red sox and an injured knee avoided him
from having to pitch against the mets
and baseball armageddon in the 86 world
series
but that summer the mets pitching staff
was in shambles so they called him and
asked him to make a comeback
and it just so happened that he and my
dad had been acquaintances from living
in greenwich connecticut together
and they were doing a baseball
memorabilia deal where my dad advertised
in the trades that seabird would sign
people mailed stuff into the post office
boxes silver would come to the house
once in a while and sit and sign well
one day he shows up with a glove
and he announces the mets want me to try
to make a comeback
and i need someone to throw to and my
dad was 55 at the time and probably
could have handled it but
being a dad passed it off to his 20 year
old tom several eleven kid
and uh i said sure mr saber i'll catch
you
so tom sat there and signed for about an
hour and while he was doing that i
called my good buddy bill simmons who
lived in the next town over i said hey
bill
in about an hour tom seaver's going to
be pitching to me in my front yard
and before i could hang up the phone
bill was in my front yard
and we go out front and tom starts
throwing and i got my first baseman's
glove because it's the biggest glove i
had
and he's saying here comes the fastball
here comes the slider and all this stuff
and i was sitting there just freaking
out because tom seaver was my idol
anybody he grew up
uh yeah that's fan and that era
you never asked who's your favorite met
you don't ask other than tom sieber
who's your favorite man because
everybody's favorite that was tom stever
so what i took from that experience i
ended up going over to his house three
more times to catch him over there
before he started to go
into the shea standing in pitch and it
gave me a great glimpse into how
competitive he was
uh in two ways one at that point in his
career he started throwing this lollipop
curveball kind of almost like an aegis
pitch
and simmons is standing there he's not
swinging the bat he's just giving thomas
strike zone
and after time there was a couple of
those curveballs bill goes you know i
think i can hit that pitch
and tom kind of looks at him [ __ ] and
goes oh really okay
you take in and you look you look for
that pitch and then proceeds to throw a
fastball about 10 feet
above his head just you know totally
safe but certainly enough to get the
message across he says that's what
happens when you look for the curveball
and then at the same time that summer
bill and i were playing a
full season 162 games of micro league
baseball it was i created the all-time
mets he had the all-time red sox
course building yeah and it was not a
defensive minded game like
it only really awarded you for your your
offensive statistics
so at that point 1987 frank tavares was
the most
offensively accomplished shortstop in
metro hat
so i'm going through my team to tom and
one of the sessions over in his house
and he says well why isn't house in your
shortstop
and so i explained the reasons he goes
no no harrison's got to be your
shortstop and of course harrelson was
his shortstop
and one probably helped him win a lot of
games but tom is a different no no
harrelson has to be your shortstop time
you don't understand it's a computer
make buddy or shortstop
so i made buddy my shirt stuff but it
was just
it was you know he was 40 41 at the time
he ended up he ended up going down to
port st lucie to pitch a simulated game
and former met great barry lyons went
six for six off of him
and tom said all right that's it i'm
done um but he gave the jersey that he
wore in the simulated game to his agent
who gave it to my dad who gave it to me
that year for christmas
i still have it um you know it's really
hard to describe
what that guy meant to mets fans because
how many franchises do you only have one
you know that
is so far above and everybody else you
could say that with jordan and the bulls
you can say that probably with brady and
the patriots you can't say that about
the yankees you can't say that about the
cowboys because they've had so many
greats
the mets we have tom seaver he put us on
the map
he carried us for as long as he did it
took him way too freaking long to decide
that they were going to put a statue of
him out in front of the park
that's a separate story but this was a
big loss for a lot of people
gussie i i i i knew giving you the floor
would be
perfect for many many reasons you're a
die-hard met fan and you
my condolences and losing your idol in
this regard and
i you know he's a top 10 new york sports
athlete period
of all time what he meant to mets fans
and so many people and what he meant to
the city and then obviously coming back
with the white sox and yankee stadium
having his big moment for 300
and the way he did it and then just you
know i i
the story just one more time don bowie
or uh ep can you put up that photograph
so you're saying this is
your driveway you are the guy you're a
god you're the guy behind home plate
wearing
the number two tank top and the guy with
the bad guy
then the guy with the bat is bill
simmons like the bill simmons
is standing there at the plate and look
at that ball just coming right in and
deceiver with that follow through
right i mean that that's the typical
siever follow-through
and so simmons literally talked trash
deceiver after seeing a couple of his
off-speed pitches that literally
happened
is that what you're saying and the whole
time standing behind seymour is my dad
and the whole time
she was giving my dad this dialogue on
the art of pitching and how you pitch to
different quadrants
and we saw him again in 2007 i was
producing uh
the hall of fame inductions i knew it
was going to be my last one so i had my
dad
fly in from california we and there's
always a party in cooperstown in the
hall of fame the night before the
ceremonies
and so there we are i bring my dad into
the into the hall of fame yep at the
saga hotel right at the at that
beautiful hotel in cooperstown yeah
but the party's in the actual hall of
fame so we're with tom seaver and all
these other
60 other living hall of famers in the
hall of fame plaque room
and they're arguing over who sections
are better or whatever and so we're
talking to tom
and the three of us my dad and i and tom
take a picture in front of his plaque
and afterwards i called my wife and i
said hey good news i got our christmas
out picture this year
that means you and the kids aren't in it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're the best gussy thanks for the
call you take care talking to you guys
right back at you that's gus ramsey long
time friend and espn producer and now
he runs dp's school of broadcasting at
full sail university down there in
central florida where the bucks are
amassing quite the team
that's fandom right there man that's
fandom